what is happening there reject nation we are back
with the most 100 positively received star wars
show to have ever existed ob1 episode 4 again
joined by our star wars expert ace ace of spades
ace tell me are you excited to see quinlan voss
qui-gon jinn assange ventress mace windway he's
back rendar the ghost of sith lord count duke
all right guys well you know what to do use the
force to leave a like yep it requires a lot of
work do that chris pratt jurassic world hand also
subscribe and click the notification bell to get
notified when our next reaction is up here on the
channel full length watch longer sync up with the
time code available for super sexy rejects over at
our patreon page thank you to the boys of prepper
for helping us edit this down and also check
out ace's youtube channel uh final cut pro or
great tutorials secret tutorial program
you're doing a good job there man
i definitely watch it every
day all right let's get to it
one of them should just be george lucas's
face those were a couple new droids in there
spark live long and jedi
nice parallel
i hear the vader voice
oh my god
this is a terrible sensory
deprivation take experience
your burns your body they just need
time we're on your beam you're safe now
where's leia oh meanwhile it's kind of
like when finn was like where's rey in
the last jedi the empire doesn't take kindly
to jedi sympathizers he will come for me oh
obi-wan is dead nobody's coming for
you hmm roken you shouldn't be here
oh there he is is that o'shea yeah i need your
help to get her back general i'm sorry but that's
not my problem you have no idea what the empire is
capable of look if you want my help you got it huh
super easy change his changes really
fast we need to find a way inside
we're not soldiers those feeders are
for hauling sewage she's 10 years old
i won't leave her there i'll go on my own
you can barely stand you're not getting
in there i'll go with him well i have
officer clearance i can get you inside
dead
you think people in star wars
take space travel for granted
god light speed is taking so long
oh look he's he's forcing it
you can't force the force man past is a hard
thing to forget and you just need time that's
all some things can't be forgotten you care
about leia then you're gonna have to try
we're almost there you're gonna have to get in
shape real quick man workout montage yes seriously
force workout safe house like the one
you were in has been found in two systems
i need to find out where they are leia
and i think you know how did he die he burned to
death on mapusa bring me his body if you tell me
where the path is you can go home to your family
i don't know anything about a path well let's
think a little bit harder shall we it's that
attitude that gets alderaan blowing up leia
it's a beautiful ass shot
just gonna walk right through
the front door identification
no admittance without clearance
i have office class c now please
that's a huge cameo
this isn't your sector i can't let you through
and i'm your commanding officer and you will
address me sir yes sir of course but i'm
here with classified intelligence do you
know what classified means yes sir
of course you're not donald gleason
hux's dad
this is old school very old school phantom menace
you should be right ahead of you this is so cool
sounds like a video game level they watched
jedi fall in order and let's do that
what did he do just threw him in the water i'm in
dang bro and i didn't get that
guy's disguise yeah should have
oh she's gonna resist contest
you've practiced our clemency
area the braver you've seen
the more afraid you are i learned
that at a very young age as well
don't don't you do it look at this
it's just hundreds of snokes
looks like they're everywhere
jesus this isn't your station come with me
damn this is the vip lounge we need
more people with your initiative
wowie
they couldn't see everyone sneak
up there but they could hear that
over there let's go well done diversion we're all
on the same side here these people they'll leave
you too to die i'll tell you where they are i just
don't want anyone to get hurt i give you my word
excellent i'll have to tell my father first it's
okay right you said we're all on the same side
nice try princess i'll never tell you where
they are it's time to make those tears real
inquisiting is hard where are you i
think i just found the secure sector
i feel like there's a twist
coming with riva let go oh let go
is that quinlan yeah place
isn't a fortress not that one
i need a distraction fine what's happened
just do it now was that the young lane at
the beginning of the show look kind of like you
did this to yourself what are you doing to me
game over i was told i cannot wait
yikes oh that's one hell of a distraction
yeah seriously i need to talk to you
i was stationed on mapuzo when the hunt began
the network runs out of the certain sector
i found evidence before the escape
impressive unless of course you're lying
stand where you are
that you wish i was gonna have built-in
sunglasses now what does not make sense
is how an old man and a little girl escaped
an imperial checkpoint on your planet hmm
admit you're a spy of course i am when kenobi
came they panicked and i got inside you expect
me to believe this i couldn't tell anybody if they
found out i would have been killed he's on floor
please don't get caught obi i want her to live
take her to interrogation ugh
if the debriefing confirms it
it's him
first time that gun's ever hit a target
there you go hell yeah
slowly getting your groove back
man i wanted to be at peaked level
so yeah you could take down like so many
oh my god
that's a good trick
wait for it wait oh dick move
you know he's keeping you guys alive right now
oh wow
put this on what a great shot that's a great shot
will suffer for this
there's gonna be so much inquisiting happening
stop how are you gonna stick it to the r-rated
movie if you keep doing that it's so close
just keep going no betraying everything you want
oh god that's never who i was and then you die
for nothing you can take him
come on do some [__] obiew
oh great
got you sully just go destroy them
the subtle use of the vader
breath and all these sound mixes
oh my god
i put a tracker on the ship
where he goes it will follow
oh okay
oh that's really sweet take her to live with luke
oh no of course yeah
it's evil no
evil reaver
did you like it more than the rise of skywalker
oh short man it was quick right it's a smooth
half hour yeah yeah i felt really quick
is that a problem oh no i don't think so john
i mean i could think of a couple moments i might
have put a little more time into suspense building
for but overall i don't think it hurts the episode
too much guys you know what gets the clicks is the
outrage i mean riva was in this episode again oh
can't handle it the outrage guys letting me town
so henry christensen was in the
back the tank i'm assuming yeah
and i think they use aspects of his voice for
vader and then maybe match some of the voice
matching software that is doing james earl jones's
voice to that oh fascinating this is a theory
but kind of like when they had a different
actor for vader in the first star wars movie
and then they said nah let's use james
earl jones forget this doughy white guy
well i think they're using the someone pointed out
they're using the reese feature technology yeah
yeah the same stuff that they did luke with so yes
i almost wonder if they have hayden christensen
do the lines and for the cadence and for that
that's a good point and then they go back and
they put james earl jones with references from all
of his performances over top of that or something
yeah ah fascinating because like la la not so
much this episode but uh one of the previous
ones there were moments where i was like i feel
like they're almost fading the two voices together
right right moments or something but
it's true all right well hey let's uh
let's talk about it let's talk
about it let's taco about it
everyone loved this episode
all right cool in the gang we are here to
talk about this episode now you know the drill
um yeah you know i got i got some uh you got to
take these shows especially this one the way that
these episodes start and stop feel so much like
i kind of wish this was a bin show because of
the way the rhythm of how these episodes start
and stop because it seems like you're supposed
to take it in as one whole package and not as an
episode by episode case especially when it's one
of those shows where the same director of each one
of every single episode so because i do have some
i do have some things i it's a lot i really
like about this show some things i really do
love and then there's other parts where i'm like i
guess i'll wait to see the final episode before i
lay down the law of opinions up in here because my
opinion holds the most highest of authorities but
we'll focus on the episode in and of itself
i'm just here to tease my outrage wokeness
right man yeah ace ace wokeness right no
not at all woke army goddamn obi-wan going
through a fortress wokeness ob woke they fighting
stormtroopers no obi-wan troopers are white i'm
just saying i'll be one a little weak that must
mean it's it's woke because because reba's strong
anyway we will we'll stop acknowledging them for
now um who went for john you go first this time
what did you think about this episode tell the
world why you thought it was perfect on every
account oh just nothing could be better about this
episode i thought this was a decent episode and
i absolutely agree with what you just said about
it feeling as though it's part the other previous
episodes up until this point have felt a bit
more well-rounded this is the shortest of them so
far and i feel like they i feel like i we say this
about disney plus shows so often is i feel like
they could have taken a little bit of that extra
time that we're accustomed to and maybe added
it back in to flesh out some of the real peril
especially as it pertains to obi-wan getting the
job done that was the thing where i was like oh
he he did it can i interrupt really quick i have a
theory as to why this episode was so short and why
some things felt like they were cut down abruptly
does anyone want to guess what my theory is
because i feel like we can guess it in this room
uh i mean they as a jedi sympathizer they
want people to also watch miss marvel tonight
uh sure yeah i think if they wanted people to
watch miss marvel they wouldn't put it in the same
way you think yeah i think that's an easier way
to do that instead of making obi-wan shorter you
think well but we also live in a world where most
people can just watch one and then the other at
midnight if they really care and they're not gonna
be in a studio shoot it's a conspiracy theory ace
i don't know about that i feel like it's
so easy to put why can't they just put miss
marvel thursday nights because man thursday is
a different day it is it takes a lot you have
to have competency takes a lot of resources
and infrastructure to upload a video file
and then set it to public if we don't compete with
ourselves someone else is going to compete with us
the boys have fridays so i don't know they're
like if they binge stranger things then yeah
they're going to bench miss marvel and obi wan
all right john sorry to interrupt i just had uh
my conspiracy theory that he agreed with all i
could think of in this episode was miss marvel
yeah uh i mean it was really cool to see just
the whole breadth of uh uh uh ace i will consult
your knowledge it's the uh imperator the the
inquisitors fortress stately inquisitor manager
is inquisitorius the fortress inquisitorius there
we go it was very cool it was very cool to be
inside there and to be on a sneaking mission and
you know to have these close calls this i really
think my favorite part of this episode was the
back and forth between riva and leia i thought
that was really good and everything else was like
cool in a video game-esque kind of way um but it
just mainly left me wanting in the sense that
like i want to really feel the tension i don't
want to be distracted by my number one pet peeve
in shows and movies where people are like talking
next to people who are going to hear and discover
them but for some reason their voices don't carry
i don't know there were just little things that
that hampered the suspense for me it was like a
really cool well-produced episode but uh yeah i
have some thoughts on the tension and suspense
of why i think overall in the show it's sort of
been lacking but again only teasing the outrage
real outrage real religious
disney disney why do you disney
ace what are your thoughts on this episode my
friend i enjoyed it man um it's definitely an
isolated shorter episode i definitely agree with
what you're saying though it definitely felt like
i could kind of just keep watching the next one
it felt more like a in between episode uh kind of
bridging probably the first half in the second
half of the season um and i felt like this was
kind of just like the rescue leia we know she's
gonna get rescued but this is how it happens let's
do a quick 30 minute episode on how it happens um
so i i did feel like it's definitely kind of like
that bridge in between one that you can kind of
quickly go through if you were in the binge model
doing that so yeah but i i definitely like what
what you were saying john as far as the set design
is so cool it's so freaking cool like seeing her
being underwater seeing obi-wan swim underwater
the the lighting was really cool like all that
stuff just works really freaking well and i
feel like that's a big plus seeing obi-wan
take down stormtroopers cool disney plus
yeah disney plus see nobody won't take down surf
troopers was cool to me um that's something we
haven't seen in a minute when their torture chair
was legitimately kind of horrifying yeah i mean
that was the scariest part of the episode
it was a little jarring to see a little girl
scream uh in a torture chamber uh that is
definitely uh that was a lot i mean it so that
probe droid in a new hope that was nothing i mean
there's there's various interrogation droids uh
throughout star wars and yeah i'm just saying
like leia's come face to face the ito interrogator
yeah i think the biggest issue i have with
this show so far um is because like i i agree
with what you guys are saying is cool it all
is cool and it's a big very cool very cool
uh that's a red arena wow wow um the oh you were
doing pitch meeting i was doing red letter b
movies so like uh yeah cause i like going through
the inquisitor fortress is awesome i i especially
after you know playing jedi fall in order like
that it's felt so much like the game look at it
it's working on the feelings i have from the game
you know it was really it was it was nice to see
that and i did like riva scenes a lot in here
uh the actors who play you know you gotta it's
child actors it's uh i find it really um mean if
you rip into a child actor and i know some people
who have done it when it comes to the late actors
and i don't think she's bad i i don't think she's
bad there are some times where like eh yeah you
know maybe you're a child actor like wait what
am i gonna tell you this is much i expect less
of you to be like so real in a certain scene
but there are times where she does feel very
real you know sometimes when she sounds like
authoritative is when i have a hard time believing
her uh specifically but for the most part i think
she does a great job and i'm not just saying that
to be nice i think she does a really good job and
i do think that back and forth to them was nice it
was kind of like a different fliparoo from grand
moff tarkin and um grogu uh where you know like
her bad not sith but sort of sith interrogating
important child you know i mean uh uh kidding off
gideon who did i say grand moff tarkin oh my bad
people are cushing back again from the grave
literally when you were saying that i was like
i was like good pull but wait i don't remember
that no yeah should i fall in order yeah guys i'm
sorry they kind of sound a little bit similar in
some way now i'm going to get crap for saying that
the letters are so different gray um i was
i was thinking of mandalorian season two um
yeah it was kind of making me think of that we're
not really sith but you know can do sort of sith
stuff whatever you don't get um uh yeah i like
that i think the biggest issue i have with this
show right now is it is this this i i like because
it's like i'm kind of back and forth i was so i
find that so warm with the whole scene with like
leia holding obi-wan's hand and you know obi-wan
feeling kind of directionless in his life like
i've just been here on tattooing watching this boy
and i i don't know if i'm contributing to this
at all and now to see this effect he's had on
layla and showing how necessary he was to
be there for and and the bond is is such
a great part of this episode at times though
the focus of this show of it being obi-wan and
leia and then trying to emit all this suspense
and danger i i have a hard time buying into it
because it's such a central focus of the show and
i don't feel the fear of it because i'm like well
obviously leia's gonna be fine it is such
an obvious thing whereas i'll feel the the
concern and worry for character whose name i'm
not currently remembering who is the taller riva
riva i'm so worried reba's gonna die no tala yeah
i'll feel concerned for tala in those scenes you
know and that's why like mandalorian works so
well because these are new characters we don't
know they're the the path they're on and there's
and so i like it here's how i would describe it i
feel like i would actually appreciate a lot of the
story more if i picked up a book and i read it and
like oh it's kind of cool to learn the backstory
of this but in terms of a suspenseful show
especially a show that's really trying to be so
suspenseful and so intense and not really do much
character exploration in between to ju like
like a lot of intimate character moment scenes
it lacks a lived-in quality yes so i'm that's a
big part of what's missing for me here is like
i like the account concept and i like the idea
and there are parts about it i really do enjoy
um but when it comes to building like actual
tension out of it i'm like nah i don't really
i don't really feel it and uh especially for
an episode like this it's supposed to be like
pulse pounding but thrusting you right
into the action and i'm like yeah
i'm kind of just watching it though
i mean i feel like the tension
feel like the tension that we're
trying to build up was more about
the safety of leia if that makes sense more than
necessarily her dying or being captured forever
like i i think that the scene where she's about to
get tortured you i i did feel the tension because
i definitely felt like oh crap this is leia you
know that's weird i didn't feel it at all really
i was like nothing's gonna happen i'm in between
you i'm like this is the most tense i feel during
this episode but it is a short-lived moment and i
feel like they maybe were afraid to go too heavily
into child and peril torture device sequence it's
so obvious something was going to happen yeah
well i mean i i i don't know i kind of felt like
they could probably go there because they hinted
at going there in a new hope uh and obviously
they've hinted at going there in a various other
media when different people are being tortured
uh so i did feel that tension i also feel like
a lot of it too has to do with more of the prequel
ideology if that makes sense where it's more about
not necessarily like oh well we know
anakin's not gonna die in this episode
we all know that and we all know that obi-wan
is going to be fine in all those other movies
but we still feel some sort of tension that's why
solo worked for me as well solo star wars story um
there was moments where you were like oh this is
crazy but we know they're going to survive you
still felt it because of the characters that were
involved in because the way it was shot produced
edited all that kind of stuff so i i i think it
works i think it works for what they're trying
to tell i just feel like this episode itself
was so quick and to the point and short that
there might not be enough to chew on necessarily
fair enough i mean like i i don't i don't agree
with these because there are some people who just
write off the concept of a prequel in in totality
of it of of what i just of the stuff i was
expressing it's like there's the difference
between something like x-men origins wolverine
and something like x-men first class to me like
x-men first class i think is so effective in one
of the best x-men movies and that's such a prequel
and you know it's going to head down a path where
like charles and eric are probably not going to be
friends with it you know and uh revenge of the
sith i think is a great film i love that movie
um but there's there's something about the the
intimate details that feels i i that's the hard
part about explaining i i i have a hard time with
different how to how to explain it because i guess
it just comes down to a subjective feeling on
the matter you know i can't convince you to
feel a certain way and you can't but but i feel
like a lot of that has to do with the season
versus the episode right where this season might
give you what you're asking for but this episode
specifically maybe didn't give you that but maybe
that's not necessarily what the episode was going
for i've never really felt it for any of the
episodes with leia of like oh no you're in danger
well i think i i think the troubling the tricky
thing about prequels is often that you're both
further along in times you have better technology
and you have the foregone conclusions and i think
the way that you it's going to come right back to
this is the way that you temper that is to really
invest us in the personal stakes the characters in
the moment so that it doesn't matter if you know
the outcome because you know how hard these trials
are going to be and again it's that lived in
quality it's like they've given it to us in little
fits and bursts and i think all the actors are
killing it for the most part i think there are you
can tell the homework is there uh and i would love
i feel like this show more than any other show
perhaps in the star wars universe uh pitched
thus far like we did so much of like boba fett of
just like looking at his past and he's with the
tuscans and it's very sort of uh poetically shot
and it's not really dialogue heavy and i'm like
you could do stuff like that here with obi-wan and
really get into his psyche because this is your
opportunity to do better what they did or at least
more agreeably for everybody what they tried to do
with luke skywalker in the last jedi you know it's
like this is a different version of obi-wan than
the pinnacles that we know him from let's dive
into that state of being and it's there in his
performance but i don't feel like it's much there
in the writing it's very action-oriented it's very
straightforward action-oriented these past couple
episodes have been i've been like that quite a bit
um ace why are we wrong i mean i i think i think
the focus i i feel like a lot of people might be
maybe it is because she's a little girl and
because it's land because it's such an iconic
character but the the focus is still on obi-wan
and i still feel like sure everything we got
from obi-wan in every single episode so far has
been killer like has been really freaking good
whether it is the acting whether it is the
backstory whether it is even the action kind
of the build up to him getting in shape uh but
i think that's kind of a cool little way of like
slowly but surely building his way up to fighting
shape i think that's something we haven't really
seen in star wars before and it's something that
is really clever the way they build it into the
show it's not necessarily you know is obi-wan
going to get out of the situation it's how is
he going to get out of the situation it's how
he's going to overcome the stormtroopers it's
how many stormtroopers he's going to take out is
he going to use the force to take them out is he
going to use this to take him out like i think
that's a clever way to get us invested into the
action is to show us his build up into the force
and using the four thousand percent as a way to
fight off these storm troopers is he
gonna go ham and just take down like 40
like all that kind of stuff to me is a really
cool way for deborah chow to kind of showcase
where obi-wan is at in this journey yeah
i like the last half of this episode a lot
the last half is what really got me very i was
that's when i was feeling it especially when he
did start using his lightsaber and started using
the force because i do like the story concept
of you know it's it's it's kind of a typical
action story just about the star wars backdrop
of you know uh traumatized action hero is retired
and then he's pulled back out of retirement to
save little girl it's it's a very got a big
beard it's logan it's a billion other action
it's a bunch of action movies and now we're
doing it with the jedi way and you're watching
him slowly get it back in tune with the force and
uh i so i i really like that whole scene you know
especially when he is holding the water and you
get to see leia really witness him being like this
guy really cares about me he's really protecting
me right now he's a he's a real jedi you know
and it's giving her something to believe in too in
terms of this rise of the rebellion um and whatnot
uh i i really i really appreciate those nuances
and those details and i guess i find myself more
often craving um the the way i'm receptive
to that i find myself craving more of that
feeling more with this show um and
and i think that's kind of what
starts to lack for me and i
had a question about vader
what's his deal in this exactly because there
was a lot of people who were bitching about
it and i was like ah i'm sure there's he's got
a motive for it a lot of people bitched about
how he could have he like wanted obi-wan to suffer
or something with the fire right and then and then
they watched him get away and he didn't like
put the fire out or try to get vape or try to
get obi-wan back in the last episode and it seemed
like he was around here at the fortress then after
all the [__] goes down he just comes storming
and like everyone good god why you know and
and so i i don't quite i feel like they'll
eventually fully reveal it to us but i'm not
quite getting what they're doing with with vader
yeah i mean i think they i think they said that he
was in mustafar and he wasn't on or he wasn't
in the fortress that he was on in his castles
so he wasn't there and i feel like that's
like a trope too with vader is that he's never
really there no like i really think that's an
actual trope yeah whether it's empire strikes back
yeah you're right about that um i think that's
something that's a really so you're the expert
to remember details that we just learned 20
minutes ago it's a way to feature other characters
especially the inquisitors and and reva and and
to not rely too heavily on vader just being like
monologuing monologue and monologuing like to make
it more about obi-wan's journey and to make vader
kind of the final threat or the final boss at the
end versus just having him show up everywhere and
chase him down and stuff i i think
that's to me that's a better way
of showcasing vader is in small bits
and pieces rather than him just kind of
running after obi-wan i think though that
the way how disney marketed this show
is working against it in a lot of ways you think
they've marketed vader a lot because that was like
the big hype about this i don't i don't i don't
know he was i mean he was in the trailer but he
wasn't like no not i mean yeah and uh i feel like
the inquisitors were trying more than twitter once
definitely but when this show was announced sure
you know like you're way more of an extreme star
wars fan than john and i yeah but we know we stay
plugged in though to what people are talking about
and even the first sizzle reel for this the the
like the first actual look at this [__] you
know and then like the promotions are all like
hayden christensen and then darth vader and then
the sizzle reel was like they're gonna battle it
out again and and justice for hayden christensen
there's so much about that and i think that
it i think they did create an expectation
in one's mind because nothing is more
intriguing i don't think anything with riva or
any of the inquisitors is more intriguing than
exploring more of that and that the depths of
that like the third episode is like the best
for many people for a reason and and and i think
that we like i like all this other stuff i mean
the inquisitors or whatever to me i like all
this other stuff for the most part but i i do
get a little bit like i wonder if like the last
episode's just gonna be so anakin obi-wan heavy
you know i imagine that's where they're going and
and i don't want to be the guy who's like bitching
about something when i know that's probably gonna
happen later on it's just will we get there
smoothly and and i don't know if you how you
felt about book of boba fett i really didn't like
the final episode i was really let down by it um
and i don't want it to be another disney plus
mess where oh it's going good it's going great
ah but man they dropped the ball in the finale
i i definitely feel you on that especially with
marvel shows for me where marvel shows tonight
and we're talking about star wars true but
you said just keep marvelous out of the mouth i
said dizzy plus did i say marvel huh huh i'm so
sorry kevin i'm sorry i'm sorry if you're watching
this mr feige please don't he will not be on
it's anymore a reason or your star wars movie
any marvel shows uh no but i do feel like i know
what you mean as far as like the finale being a
little bit too much versus trying to focus on the
like we're gonna wrap this [__] up on the story
yeah to me i i don't know because i i don't really
when it comes to marketing it's difficult
because you do want to have when you have
an actor like hayden christensen come back
for a role whether it be a small part in the
role whether it be a huge part in the role
i think you have to feature him in marketing
as far as in press and stuff like that because
it's a way to give credence to an actor that has
been a part of star wars for such a long time to
be completely honest i think me and a few other
people out there i think as far as star wars
youtube channel star wars explained for example
didn't have those high expectations when it came
to hating christensen because we kind of were like
okay they're featuring him a lot in
marketing it doesn't necessarily mean
we're gonna get flashbacks of hayden we're
gonna get vader or a bunch of times out of
the suit like we kind of expected very little
because we know that at this point in his life
anakin is vader so the very few times we will
see hayden is going to be few and far between so
i feel like that was more of just like a shout out
a credence a appreciation for hayden more than it
was like oh he's going to be in every episode and
he's going to be featured and we're going to get
a back story we're going to get flashback like i
didn't feel that when it came to the marketing i
just felt like this is hayden christensen he's
worthy of being recognized as anakin and vader
i just keep wondering what the emotional direction
of the show is going for with obi-wan too you're
like how is this guy gonna arc into the obi-wan
who's like alright so i'm going back to tattooing
i'm just going to hang out here for a while
now yeah i mean i i think we'll figure that
out though i still feel like we have time
um it's an hour and a half of this left ace
come on maybe an hour and 45 minutes if episode
if the last one's long we talked about the outrage
it's difficult for me to pre-judge something when
it's not finished no that's why i love you because
it's way too reasonable that's very no that's very
true man that's very true it's very true like yo
rescued ladies so i'm underwater this show sucks
like for me it's like i'm not saying that let's
uh other people i don't know but i'm saying like i
think i think we still have a story to tell i feel
like a story isn't just uh you know one journey
a story is a you know sections and factions of
sure little adventures how do we get to where we
are uh what happens as far as along the journey
to get there true and i'm just saying i guess
for me i don't know how you feel it's like the
the journey for me has been a little emotional
emotionally hit and miss for me to like
cool information to oh i'm actually really
invested in this and and every episode is kind
of episode three i was invested really invested
it for the most part but the other the other ones
i've i'm kind of like really weaving in and out
of i'm just kind of gathering information versus
i'm really feeling this moment that's
why i would not write this show off
um no i i think i mean i think especially
with this show there's something fair to be
said for the idea that it is being
billed heavily as a limited series
so in that sense i'm like yes benefit of the doubt
let's see how the whole thing looks at the end
however i would say we are now four episodes in
out of six and i feel like for my experience there
to be satisfied at this point i feel like there's
gonna be a lot of emotional leg work to do in the
last two episodes because the show has felt
very again straightforward and plot oriented
and and looking at even the core you know sort of
relationship and distance between uh obi-wan and
anakin vader you know even that like vader shows
up and is really scary for moments uh but i feel
like you know most of what i know about what that
story's development is thus far as vader's pretty
upset and traumatized over the last time he
saw obi-wan so he kind of wants to get him and
probably hurt him i guess the emotional meat is
there it's just not taking center stage for me um
yeah i mean i i think to be honest it's it's a lot
to do with this episode i feel like this episode
was very much like you think it's all about this
one episode no i'm saying it i'm saying the the i
mean the meat of this episode was so thin that
it's just a little bit difficult to to kind of
like feel it in this episode and i agree with you
guys when it comes to like really having something
to chew on and the emotional stakes in this
episode because there wasn't a lot there unless
you were like you said john a fan of that uh leia
and reva interaction but other than that that was
kind of it the rest of the episode was much more
of like how do we go from point a to point b which
is probably a detriment to the episode but again
like you said john i feel like when it comes to
the complete package of it i i don't know i
think a lot of it too has to do with perhaps
the way we view different shows nowadays sure i
just binge stranger things i think if i saw like
episode three or episode two by itself i probably
wouldn't be that invested if i'm being honest uh
but seeing like three or four episodes in a row
it made me feel a little bit more hooked and made
me feel a little bit more connected to where the
story was going and even then it still very much
felt like half a story which again it is it's
part one but i feel like that's just the way we're
viewing different episodes and shows now it's like
we're taking bits and pieces of a story versus
the entire story the way you feel about stranger
things is how i feel about this yeah yeah gotcha
i'd agree with that because i feel like i don't
know man i still feel like if i'm being real uh
i think i got more in these three episodes than i
did probably in the first three of stranger things
i think golly i think ace isn't coming back
forever it's it's been nice to know you
megna is out to get him see those are going to the
upside there that show i was like put that thing
week to week and this one i'm wondering maybe this
would like you said earlier maybe this would make
it better be interesting yeah i i didn't feel
that way especially with an episode like this
uh it makes me really feel like this
might have been better if i watched
this episode might have been better
if i just watched it immediately after
but even then it's like this i don't know there's
something about it this one was it also did
feel really rushed it's like you meet o'shea
jackson who's like no i'm not helping you five
seconds later all right i talked myself into about
remembering why i'm doing this in the first place
you know that was just for me guys like
i i and then these people die at the end
and to be honest or that guy that the weight guy
dies at the end and i don't i don't give a [__]
like i'm like honestly dude i don't even remember
you from five minutes ago like i don't remember
who you are and we walk around inside of a jedi
tomb trophy room you know which is that's right
and i think i think i don't want to say the word
milk it ah live in it live in it yeah like live in
it or do some like hollywood romanticizing or
some [__] terminology of of like let's like
like obi-wan fighting the stormtroopers and using
his powers actually watching him get his powers
back like really make a strong emotional moment
out of that you know more like oh that might just
be the like the way it's edited or the way it
breathes sometimes of like that scene when when
leia holds his hand that took its time and that
hit and they could have done that with so many
more moments in this one episode that if you're
not gonna do like a bunch of dialogue exchanges to
uncover character background at least really let
those moments hit i agree i i feel like oh my god
something welcome to the time i've been sweating i
disagree i've changed my mind yeah we're so close
so much better this year at every criticism
you have is valid but i don't feel like
that's necessarily a criticism of the show
more than it is a criticism of this episode
this episode did feel like it was rushed it
did feel like it didn't have as much meat
to it it did feel like it didn't have as much
emotional stakes to it but i feel like that's
more a detriment to a standalone episode more
than it is a detriment to the entire shows
in general amen um i hope you are correct yeah
well guys do you prefer this for stranger things
i prefer this wow really how about the
boys anybody no i i don't see the boys
i don't watch the boys wow thanks for not
helping that go watch this morning reaction
right now disney plus everything's out all right
guys yeah well leave your thoughts down below
um that's good good open discussion this was a
nice discussion guys i did it i'm a tad harsher
ace is a lot more happy you're like kind of in
between that's right i'm the gray jedi either
we don't talk about it it's not canon i
guess but maybe i'm the jedi who's like
[__] jedi i can't muslim i swear to push me
in the goddamn dark side of that jedi skywalker
can be repressed a bit follow jedi do
you think we'll see quinlan vos i mean
that kind of looked like quinlan boss in that and
officially he is and okay i'm sorry to say this
if it is quinlan boss and they
didn't make a moment out of it
this show's [__] this and that's not just
because oh my god we're using clone wars and
you're ruining no they had a whole moment in the
last episode when he's like yeah quinlan was here
but i'm not going to spend any time with his
course yeah i'm not going to even acknowledge but
even yeah like but that scene too would have just
really hit of just that could have been a big most
triggering moment for him should have been that
moment yeah you know i mean seeing that youngling
was was was it was quick but it was still like oh
we should have lingered on this a tiny bit more
yeah so yeah wow how'd they embalm them like that
who whose idea was it to be like you put the hat
back on that young lady they saw jurassic park and
they were like let's let's get us some amber and
let's freeze some moments in time do you like
his outfit i think we should change it like no
probably though like that's how just that's how
sick they are they probably do like like a museum
they primp them yeah yeah we gotta get one of
those yeah we need a tomb hallway promise me
when i dies i have one of those in your home yeah
me but but make sure that's like we're gonna pose
you the right way yeah i want to be one of the
hard-to-reach corpses on the second level that
you can't really sit and admire it reminded me
of uh of the scene in young justice where they
have him in stasis uh i think it's desperate
where they or [__] it might be [__] where
they keep him don't mess this up man um it's very
similar like if i show you guys an image you guys
will be like oh they could have taken it from that
because it looks very similar well dude star wars
is all about easter eggs and references now that's
all matters as long as you do that you're in there
you're gonna start referencing other ips now star
wars gonna get really have you seen young justice
somehow the longest video of ours is the
shortest episode of star wars we had to make
up for last time like what the hell did we just
think we just inserted the whole episode here
all right all right guys this video is
truly done but before that let's do a page
andrew hayes so andrew hey something about
andrew hayes you probably get along with
this guy pretty well uh he's been like one
of our patrons for the longest time years man
years uh short stocky fella cat talks like this
and uh he's he and he's a freaking he's like
adorable but intimidate the same time you know
he's like wolverine yeah yeah yeah he's great
um and uh he was telling me a story recently
about how he was at a bachelor party this is true
i don't know if you know if you want some reveal
i might have this is where i've severed the cord
no longer a picture of my
favorite told you this is
uh he was at a bachelor party and and then they
got kicked out of uh i believe it was a strip club
before they thought they they were soliciting
prostitution there and uh legalize it and i i
i would believe i mean and to be frank andrew if
i saw you and i heard that i would be like yeah
probably i mean look at the guy right this guy
who loves prostitution he looks like the kind of
guy he would right just get you a leather jacket
he'll still stick around you could be a crooked
how do you survive andrew and then uh and then
a friend of theirs um they went home on a on a
scooter like an electric scooter and they lost
the scooter and their phone on the way home
and they didn't know how they didn't
know how to get home for a while
so and then the prostitutes all showed up and
helped yes gave them a lift they all pushed a
scooter they all ironically leaned out the window
themselves and said hey do you need a ride sexual
services we're also a towing where'd you play
yeah if you subscribe we'll get you out of a jam
it's all right we get a new battery get new tires
andrew you don't need to go down that path but if
you do there's nothing wrong with it but you don't
need to do it you can get a woman all on your own
i believe in you andrew i mean if it's wolverine
then yeah he cut some women up if you slash
that seems better than love yeah and if they stick
around with you then you know you got real love
ain't that right ace that's right real love baby
are you sick bastard i was making a joke wow don't
you have a a woman on your channel a squad leader
respect women how would you how would you feel if
she heard you say yes and to that well sabrina
would you come in here please we got sabrina oh
we have sabrina here we had a big surprise caught
in the act we're here to get you canceled today
i'm just hitting cameras everywhere ashton kutcher
come on out ashton kutcher he's still alive he's
yeah yeah yeah he invests in in big tech now
like andrew could someday after he gets out of
his jail shot prostitution this is the longest
non-shout out we've ever done thanks andrew
you